travis barker is letting the world know
how deep his love for kourtney
kardashian goes
the blink 182 musician shared a snap of
himself passionately kissing his fiancee
on instagram
captioning it quote i would die for you
i mean it was beautiful amazing courtney
responded to travis's post by commenting
under the pic quote you i would die for
you it's always amazing the couple's
latest display of public affection comes
after courtney shared blurry late night
photos of herself driving with travis in
the passenger seat captioning the
image's quote daddy had a buick and mama
loved to ride we're having so much fun
speaking of fun back in 2021 courtney
put her tattooing skills to the test and
inked the words i love you on travis's
forearm and travis revealed in december
that out of the 100 plus tattoos he has
court's personalized one is his favorite
i love it courtney and travis were first
linked together romantically in january
of 2021 and got engaged last october
after being friends and neighbors for
years
now according to a source the couple is
planning their quote intimate and
special wedding the source also tells et
quote courtney and travis want to get
married sooner than later and the
wedding planning has already begun and
things are in motion
adding quote they want their wedding to
be really exclusive and are so looking
forward to spending the rest of their
lives together
we're so excited to be here this is
insane someone who apparently is not so
excited about all the wedding talk is
courtney's ex scott disick
a source tells e.t that scott the father
of courtney's three children is quote
not thrilled about the idea of courtney
and travis getting married and is still
processing it however it's noted quote
courtney and scott have been getting
along just fine there's no bad blood and
balancing the time with the kids has
never been a huge issue for them in 2019
scott opened up to e.t about how
throughout all their ups and downs over
the years he and court have always
managed to keep the kids first i mean i
think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day i mean there's
so many different things that could pull
you in different directions and you can
look online and instagram social media
and all these things but
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy life is a challenge
and if you work at what you want you can
get it but it takes hard work simple as
that
you